there's certain things that i knew about
this kid
when we drafted him he was tough
he was competitive
and in my opinion he's a winner now the
rest of it is just pure quarterback
stuff and because of those first three
things that's why he's going to have a
chance moving forward
a little vindication for pat shermer in
the new york giants after daniel jones
makes his debut with a victory over the
tampa bay buccaneers with an assist from
bruce arians and the intentional or not
delay of game penalty but still the
giants win daniel jones checks the boxes
the question now guys and i'll start
with peter king can daniel jones keep
this going
mike i think he can but i think the re
the expectations have to be realistic
because i mean there's washington this
week
and then there's new england and
minnesota consecutively in some order i
forget
but you know they're gonna face
some some very good defenses here coming
up quickly
and i think here you go and and i think
the one thing to think about with daniel
jones is i know everybody saw how he
played and didn't make very many of any
major mistakes in that first game i
think it's unrealistic as a first year
starter to expect wonderland every
sunday
so to me this has to be
incremental progress in daniel jones so
that by the time you get to new year's
day you look and you say okay
we definitely have our quarterback of
the future and he's ready now we've got
to patch some holes we need
a franchise wide receiver we need one
more 10-year offensive lineman somewhere
preferably at left tackle and we need a
pass rusher desperately so but but again
the most important thing is you've
solved the quarterback thing and so
whatever happens in the next few weeks
unless it's a disaster and nobody thinks
it will be
the best thing that daniel jones has
given them is 2021 peace of mind yeah i
think that's uh all valid points
definitely i mean he's he's given the
whole organization a future and hope and
i mean that's why i think the giant fan
base now is very excited for the daniel
jones era one they got to see eli kind
of fail one more time and then they got
to see daniel jones and how different
the team looked how much more exciting
they were on the offensive side of the
ball because of his talent you know can
he sustain this success you know i'm not
expecting him to go out there and throw
you know for 330-something yards and
four touchdowns every week you know he
did lose two fumbles right in the game
he also threw two bad balls that hit
buccaneers players right in the chest so
you know
some point the defense is gonna catch
some of those plays but regardless yeah
they're gonna be playing without a
saquon barkley it's gonna be a lot on
his shoulders but i think you're playing
the washington redskins this week who
don't play very good past defense we
could see similar type numbers and then
maybe back to reality like peter said
when the vikings and the new england
patriots come to town and that'll be a
different ball game because of their
defenses
and it almost doesn't matter peter like
you're saying for 2019 that this is
about passing the baton from eli manning
to someone who will be the quarterback
for more than a year or two to avoid
falling into that never-ending churn of
we tried this guy for a while and it
didn't work we signed this guy and it
didn't work you know the post-peyton
manning plan in denver that's what the
giants wanted to avoid post eli manning
where you're constantly just grasping
and groping for any quarterback who
could potentially come in and make
things better now they have a guy that
they can feel good about they can build
around they can draft around they can
attract free agents around because
people are going to say hey that's a
place i can go and potentially win
because if you have a good quarterback
then everything else can build out
around him so so peter i think that that
you're right this regardless of what
happens this year this is about having
the best possible transition from eli
manning to whoever follows eli manning
yeah and mike there's one other point to
make about all this okay and that is
that the new york giants very clearly
have fallen way behind dallas and
philadelphia way behind
and the only way you start to catch up
is to solve the problem that you've had
at quarterback that too few people have
seemed to acknowledge that no matter how
great eli manning has been as a person
and for your history with the two super
bowls it was long past time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports